die 2010er jahre brachten uns
gesichtserkennung und die pigs
smartphones und tablets sind inzwischen
aus unserem alltag nicht mehr
wegzudenken und e-mobility also e bikes
e scooter und e autos gehören fest zu
unserem stadtbild dazu zusätzlich haben
die block chain und crypto währungen den
finanzmarkt auf den kopf gestellt all
diese themen habe ich in den letzten
jahren hier auf dem kanal schon sehr
viel besprochen
jetzt stehen wir aber kurz vor der wende
in ein neues jahrzehnt
was wird in den nächsten zehn jahren
thematisch auf diesem kanal passieren
und wie wird sich unser leben in der
nächsten dekade verändern
genau darum geht es in diesem video
[Musik]
eines der beliebtesten themen auf diesem
kanal ist in den letzten jahren das
selbst fahrende auto gewesen
google tesla gm und mercedes arbeiten
alle seit einigen jahren an dieser
technologie
laut dem bundesministerium für verkehr
und infrastruktur sterben in deutschland
pro tag neun menschen bei
verkehrsunfällen risiko verursache
nummer eins ist hier der menschen
91 prozent der unfälle lassen sich auf
menschliche fehler zurückführen
technische fehler machen lediglich einem
prozent aus es liegt also nahe dieses
risiko zu minimieren und die beste
möglichkeit wirst du den menschen aus
dem verkehr zu ziehen
ganz alleine darf ein auto nach
deutschem recht zwar noch nicht fahren
und trainierte fahrer müssen selbst bei
googles mail noch regelmäßig die
kontrolle übernehmen
wie realistisch ist das also dass bis
2030 jedes auto eigenständig fahren kann
dies wurde auf der zschopauer auto
revolution konferenz 2009/10 debattiert
branchenexperten sehen erste breite
einführung in autonomer technologien im
verkehr innerhalb der nächsten acht oder
neun jahre die wissenschaftler rechnen
mit fünf bis 15 jahren bis autonomes
fahren auch für den konsumenten möglich
sein wird es könnte also tatsächlich
passieren dass das zumindest gegen ende
der dekade alles passiert 2017 hat sich
eine ethikkommission der deutschen
regierung zusammengesetzt um die zukunft
des autonomen fahrens in deutschland zu
klären so ist autonomes fahren erlaubt
die mitfahrt in einem auto ohne fahrer
bleibt jedoch erst mal verboten bis die
technologie dafür bereit ist
politisch werden also eindeutig schon
weichen gestellt um ethischen und
rechtlichen hindernissen vorzubeugen
inwiefern die technologie praktisch in
den nächsten zehn jahren bereit sein
wird das bleibt allerdings abzuwarten
die bundeskommission und führende
wissenschaftler rechnen aber mit einem
positiven effekt auf die
straßensicherheit allein schon durch
teilautonome assistenzsysteme andere
wissenschaftler bemerken dass auch
selbst fahren autos fehler machen werden
selbst wenn sie sicherer sind als
menschliche fahrer einig ist man sich
auf jeden fall beim ökologischen aspekt
von selbstfahrenden autos selbst mit
fossilen brennstoffen autonome autos
sind spritsparender unterwegs und
deswegen nachhaltiger
die globale klimakrise stellt eine
riesige gefahr für uns alle da schon in
den letzten jahren hat man deswegen
eifrig an erneuerbaren energien
geforscht solarzellen und
windkraftanlagen erweisen sich zwar als
grüne aber wetterabhängige lösungen
flächendeckend und co2 armen aber leider
gefährlich sind kernkraftwerke
außerdem hat deutschland den ausstieg
bis 2022 bereits festgelegt so groß ist
die sorge fatale unfälle wie tschernobyl
oder fukushima zu riskieren
im süden frankreichs wird seit 2013 aber
ein nukleares mega projekt gebaut das
vielleicht all diese probleme lösen
könnte der etat das steht für
internationaler thermonukleare
experimenteller reaktor
dieser wird von der eu china indien
korea russland und den usa unterstützt
18 milliarden euro soll die konstruktion
dieses mega experimentes insgesamt
kosten
der etat soll atome nicht teilen sondern
miteinander fusionieren
daher wird auch von fusionsenergie
gesprochen unter hohen temperaturen und
mit viel druck werden dort helium und
tritium beides wasserstoff isotope zu
helium fusioniert dabei entsteht ein
zusätzliches neutron das dann dafür
genutzt wird um ein wasserbecken zu
erhitzen welches turbinen antreibt die
wiederum elektrizität erzeugen eine
erfolgreiche fusion entsteht im etat
aber erst ab circa 15 millionen grad
celsius
um das zu erreichen soll sich der etat
einem talker markt bedienen 1 talker mag
das ist eine kombination aus magneten
welche ein ringförmiges und polo ideales
magnetfeld erzeugen
dieses magnetfeld schließt diese gruppe
ein um sie dann zu erhitzen
das hierfür benötigte deuterium lässt
sich einfach aus meerwasser gewinnen
kernfusion bietet also eine virtuell
unerschöpflichen vorrat an energie
außerdem bietet fusion den vorteil dass
weniger radioaktiver müll produziert
wird der gleichzeitig auch nicht so
lange aktiv ist zusätzlich produziert
kernenergie sehr wenig co2 emissionen
bis wir aber in den genuss von
flächendeckender fusionsenergie kommen
muss der etat erst einmal fertig gebaut
werden und selbst an das nicht klar wie
erfolgreich die experimente wirklich
sein werden
nach geplanter fertigstellung 2025
sollen dann zehn jahre lang tests
stattfinden vielleicht sehen wir also
bis 2030 erst der erfolgreiche
kernfusion iter und somit einen weiteren
schritt in richtung sauberer fuß
energie nachhaltigkeit wird sich aber
nicht nur im energiesektor durchsetzen
müssen
auch in unserem lebensmittelkonsum wird
sich etwas ändern in den letzten zwölf
jahren hat sich nach den vereinten
nationen die weltbevölkerung um eine
milliarde menschen vergrößert
bis 2030 soll sie 8,6 milliarden
erreichen eine wachsende weltbevölkerung
wirkt sich natürlich auch auf die
massentierhaltung aus und schon jetzt
ist sich die wissenschaft mit einer
bedeutenden mehrheit einig die
benötigten ressourcen für die haltung
zum fleischverzehr hinterlassen
alarmierende treibhausgasemissionen
während ihr alle bestimmt schon mal
vegetarische oder vegane ersatzprodukte
probiert haben werdet rechnen experten
innerhalb der nächsten zehn jahre mit
einem trend der die
lebensmittelindustrie im sturm erobern
soll
in vitro fleisch oder auch labor fleisch
die produktion dieses bio fabrizierten
fleisches ist inzwischen keine
zukunftsmusik mehr
so wird muskelgewebe in einem flüssigen
medium kultiviert hierzu werden die
gezüchteten erwachsenen muskelzellen
sozusagen geerntet und können in
verschiedenen fleisch varianten
verarbeitet werden durch das kultivieren
gelöster mio satellit zellen wächst
tatsächlich echtes fleisch und das kann
man unter dem mikroskop nicht vom
fleisch aus der kühltheke unterscheiden
so weit so ekelig in vitro fleisch ist
aber ein radikaler neuer weg welcher
sowohl ökologische als auch ethische
vorteile bietet zusätzlich erlaubt bio
fabriziert das fleisch das eliminieren
von allergie auslösern und anderen
krankheiten die von fleisch übertragen
werden können jedoch scheitert in vitro
fleisch aktuell am preis für einen kilo
müsst ihr bis zu 90.000 euro in die hand
nehmen zur zeit benötigt die produktion
einer wurst stolze 3000 petrischalen
kommerzialisierung und massenproduktion
lassen aber ja bekanntlich preise sinken
können wir also bis 2030 mit einer
großflächig angelegten produktion von
labor fleisch rechnen
eine reihe von labor fleisch startups
möchte bis 2030 in massenproduktion
gehen oftmals benutzen diese startup
jedoch noch stammzellen junge kälber zur
züchtung des fleisches
so würde sich die massentierhaltung zwar
drastisch verringern tier frei und ohne
leiden ist die produktion dann aber
wiederum nicht
die forschung ist einfach noch nicht
weit genug für eine massenproduktion
ohne tierische stammzellen für eine
ethisch korrekte bratwurst aus 3000
petrischalen müssen wir uns also noch
ein paar jahre gedulden
attraktiv wäre in vitro auch aus
gesundheitlichen gründen das
heranzüchten nach wunsch erlaubt nämlich
die mitgestaltung der muskelzellen
ihr könnt euch also zum beispiel euer
eigenes schnitzel designen ganz ohne
knüppel oder fettablagerungen ergo
optimierung und freie gestaltung und das
ist auch das nächste thema 2018 hat
nämlich ein chinesischer forscher
angekündigt mit der gen schere chris
bourque essen ein zwei zwillinge
lebenslang vor dem hi virus geschützt zu
haben
und das bereits vor der geburt und noch
im herbst diesen jahres kündigte der
russische forscher des re break of an
durch die manipulation ungeborene kinder
vor angeborener taubheit bewahren zu
wollen werden wir bis 2030 also in der
lage sein unsere kinder ganz nach wunsch
zu gestalten
experten der whu debattierten schon im
frühjahr 2009 10 über ethische und
wissenschaftliche dimensionen von
designerbabys möglich ist die
manipulation der embryos durchaus in
deutschland sieht die wissenschaftlerin
professor doktor alena büchs eine sehr
zeitnahe anwendung von genmanipulationen
zum korrigieren von angeborenen
krankheiten die deutsche ethikkommission
spricht in bezug auf die positive
veränderung des erbguts aber von einem
großen risiko positiv heißt nicht dass
korrigieren von angeborenen krankheiten
sondern vorbeugende eingriffe in die dna
des menschen
hierbei besteht die gefahr dass dies zu
unvorhersehbaren folgen führt wir wissen
tatsächlich nicht wie dna genau
funktioniert selbst wenn es im ersten
moment nicht auffällt kann es sein dass
es erst generationen später zu
schwerwiegenden genetischen schäden
kommt
auch auf ethischer ebene sind designer
babys extrem umstritten wie weit wollen
wir in die evolution eingreifen machen
uns unsere makel nicht auch irgendwo
menschlich und vor allem wer kann sich
das dann alles leisten
trotz dieser großen reihe an
kritikpunkten forschen immer mehr
wissenschaftler an chris bourque es
neigen
hinzu kommt dass organisationen wie die
whu keine verbindlichen regeln
aufstellen dürfen
es bleibt also ländern selbst überlassen
in die fernseh genmanipulationen an
ungeborenen kindern bestrafen oder
vielleicht sogar fördern wollen
demnach ist es gar nicht so
unrealistisch dass bis 2030 die erste
baby design klinik eröffnet
hinter designerbaby steckt unbestreitbar
der wunsch den menschen zu verbessern
also das bedürfnis nach optimierung und
leistungssteigerungen bei trekking durch
zum beispiel smart watch ist erfreut
sich einer wachsenden beliebtheit wie
weit entwickeln sich also tragbare
technologien im nächsten jahrzehnt und
wird es sogar bis 2030 normal sein sich
mikrochip zu implantieren
schon dieses jahr hat ein forschungsteam
der stanford university ein erstes
produkt des buddy net programms
vorgestellt
tragbare technologie welche unsere
körperlichen prozesse überwachen soll
so kann ein dieses jahr entwickelt das
ticker auf der haut schon schlaf zyklen
und den puls überwachen und das ganz
ohne batterien die ist die antwort
university zeigt sich auch
zuversichtlich für eine baldige nutzung
in der allgemeinmedizin okay wie sieht
es aber bei implantierter technologie
aus schon 2004 ließ sich der damals
farbenblinde britische künstler nil
haben eine antenne in seinen kopf
implantieren welches ihm erlaubt farben
zu hören
dabei hört er sogar mehr als das was du
und ich sehen können da diese antenne
auch auf seinem reisepass zu sehen ist
gilt habe sind als der erste formelle
staatlich anerkannte cyborg zum cyborg
werden könnt ihr auch jetzt schon
nämlich indem ihr zu einem von über 100
ps an in deutschland geht und durch
einen gerade mal 50 euro teuren nfc-chip
hier implantieren lassen
das tut auch nicht besonders weh und
damit könnt ihr euch dann ausweisen
damit bezahlen oder diesen nfc-chip als
schlüssel nutzen ganz so fern ist unser
cyborg da sein also tatsächlich doch
nicht
vom menschen der mehr und mehr maschine
wird zur maschine die immer menschlicher
wird siri google assistent oder alexa
sind heutzutage kaum wegzudenken
während diese virtuellen assistenten
immer schlauer werden debattiert die
wissenschaft über die zukunft von
künstlicher intelligenz je nach
auffassung zeichnen wissenschaftler
verschiedenste bilder von einer zukunft
in der ki eine immer größere rolle
spielt schaut euch dazu gerne auch unser
video über die zukunft von künstlicher
intelligenz an in der wir euch sechs
verschiedene szenarien vorgestellt haben
wie schätzen also experten die
entwicklung und anwendung künstliche
intelligenz in den nächsten zehn jahren
ein
das forbes magazine rechnen damit dass
künstliche intelligenz der
weltwirtschaft bis 2030 ungefähr 14
millionen euro einbringen wird
es wird also mit einem riesigen wachstum
gerechnet dass nicht nur durch smarte
assistenten kommen wird das pew research
center hat letztes jahr knapp 1000
experten auf dem gebiet befragt wie sie
den einfluss künstlicher intelligenz bis
2030 einschätzen
63 prozent davon gehen davon aus dass
sich durch das leben der meisten
menschen verbessert haben wird andere
sind sogar noch optimistischer
eric buisson direktor sieht ki in der
lage bis 2030 globale armut zu besiegen
und bessere bildungsmöglichkeiten für
alle zu schaffen indem zum beispiel die
ki nahrung und geld besser verteilt
andere wissenschaftler entgegnen dass
dies war technisch möglich sein wird
sich aber unser verhältnis zu
technologie und vor allem der
vermarktung von technologien verändern
muss privatisiert und mit einem
preisschild wird ki die welt armut nicht
lösen können demnach ist man sich einig
dass technologie sich unseren werten
anpassen muss und nicht umgekehrt
das sich bis 2030 weiter entwickeln wird
ist also sehr wahrscheinlich wie unsere
realität beeinflusst hängt aber viel
mehr davon ab wie zugänglich die
vorteile von ki für uns alle gemacht
werden
was meint ihr dazu was sind eure
vorhersagen für die nächsten zehn jahre
sagt er optimistisch und glaubt dass in
zehn jahren dank ki niemand mehr hungern
muss oder seid ihr eher der meinung dass
wir bis dahin in einer zwei klassen
gesellschaft leben in der sich nur die
reichen intelligente und gesunde babys
leisten können schreibt es mir gerne
unten in die kommentare
ich bin sehr auf eure meinungen gespannt
vielen dank an dieser stelle an alle
leute die uns auf kathrin unterstützen
ihr habt uns ermöglicht dieses jahr mehr
und bessere videos zu machen deswegen
viele nehmen dank jemals weihnachten an
eure unterstützung und wir freuen uns
auf 2020 mit euch falls ihr petra noch
nicht kennt dann erste link unten in der
video beschreibung gerne einmal
anklicken gibt es viele vorteile für
euch können zum beispiel videos früher
gucken oder krieg behind the scenes
einblicke in das was wir hier so alles
machen und es wird uns auf jeden fall
sehr helfen im jahr 2020 noch mehr und
noch bessere videos zu machen
in diesem sinne vielleicht fürs
zuschauern bleibt neugierig patrick
[Musik]